We were able to solve our
sports scheduling problem
with 4 teams, 24 decision
variables, and 22
basic constraints,
pretty quickly.
However, the problem
size increases rapidly.
The same problem
with 10 teams, would
have 585 decision variables
and 175 basic constraints.
For scheduling major
league baseball,
the problem has 100,000
decision variables
and 200,000 constraints.
For small problems, spreadsheet
softwares, like LibreOffice,
are great.
But for large
problems like this,
solving them in LibreOffice
would be impossible.
So how are integer
optimization models like this
solved in practice?
Many different tricks are
used to solve large integer
optimization problems.
One is to reformulate
the problem.
The sports scheduling
problem with more teams
is often solved by
changing the formulation.
Instead of the
decision variables
we discussed in this
lecture, the variables
are sequences of games.
Additionally, the problem can
be split into three smaller
problems that can each be self
separately and much faster
than just solving
the whole problem.
Another trick that's
often used, is
what are called
Heuristic methods.
These methods find good, but not
necessarily optimal decisions.
A good decision is
sometimes accepted
since the problem
is so much easier
to solve using a
heuristic method.
In addition to changing
the formulation
in using heuristics, there are
general purpose optimization
solvers that can
solve large problems.
These include CPLEX,
Gurobi, GLPK and Cbc,
a COIN-OR project.
Most practitioners who solve
large optimization problems
use one of these
software packages.
And in the past 20 years, the
speed of integer optimization
solvers has increased
by a factor of 250,000,
which doesn't even include the
increasing speed of computers.
Assuming a modest
machine speedup of 1,000,
this means that a
problem that can
be solved in one second
today, took seven years
to solve 20 years ago.
Because of this
increase in speed
were able to solve much
larger and more complicated
optimization problems today,
than just a few years ago.
So how about the sports
scheduling problem?
When the Sports Scheduling
Group was started in 1996,
integer optimization software
was too slow to be useful.
Now, they can use
powerful solvers
to generate sports schedules.
Even with these
solvers, it can take
months to make the major
league baseball schedule.
This is due to several reasons,
including the enormous list
of ever changing
constraints that they
have to account for, the
need to define priorities
on the constraints to find a
feasible solution, and the fact
that it takes several iterations
to get a good schedule.
But even with these
challenges, analytics
offers a significant edge
in sports scheduling.
The use of optimization
allows for the addition
of new constraints
or schedule changes.
A new schedule can
easily be generated
based on an updated
requirement or request.
Now, all professional sports
and most college sports,
construct their schedules
using optimization.
In this lecture, we've seen
one powerful use of integer
optimization, but this
method has a huge number
of applications,
which you'll see
more of in the second
lecture, The Recitation,
and in the homework assignment.